aquí tenemos a este vector w y nos dan
algo de información acerca de él nos
dicen que su punto inicial es el punto
menos 73 y también sabemos que su punto
final es el 2 menos 1 y a partir de esto
quiero averiguar la magnitud del vector
w así que quiero obtener la magnitud del
vector w la magnitud del vector w y
bueno como siempre te pido que pausa el
vídeo y veas si puedes llegar al
resultado bueno primero qué te parece si
usamos estos datos y resolvemos el
problema y después lo grafica vamos para
ver si nuestro resultado tiene sentido
así que una forma de ver esto es
recordar que déjame cambiar de color que
la magnitud de no espera espera sigue
siendo el mismo color así que me tomaré
el color amarillo que la magnitud
el vector w esto va a ser igual a quien
bueno esto va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada a la raíz cuadrada de el cambio
en x esto elevado al cuadrado más el
cambio en el cambio en esto también
elevado al cuadrado y bueno cuál va a
ser nuestro cambio en x
bueno pues recuerda que delta de x el
cambio en x esto lo puedes ver como el
valor de x en el punto final menos el
valor de x del punto inicial lo cual es
bueno esto es lo mismo que 2
- 7 negativo entonces me va a quedar
2 - menos 7 y esto lo podemos resolver
esto es lo mismo que en 2007 lo cual es
y esto tiene sentido porque para ir de
menos siete astados se debe de aumentar
en siete para llegar al cero y después
dos unidades más para llegar al 2
positivo así que tienes que aumentar 9
unidades en total o dicho de otra manera
delta de x es igual a 9 muy bien y ahora
cuánto va a ser nuestro cambio en james
cuánto va a ser nuestro cambio en game
bueno pues nuestro cambio en james va a
ser igual al valor de y en el punto
final menos el valor de y en el punto
inicial el valor de y en el punto final
es menos 1
entonces me va a quedar menos 1 ya esto
le voy a quitar el valor de y en el
punto inicial así que menos uno menos
tres y bueno esto es lo mismo que menos
vamos a ver si entendimos bien vamos a
empezar en tres y después vamos a tener
que bajar hasta menos uno lo que quiere
decir que esta cantidad es negativa
porque vamos a bajar y cuánto tenemos
que bajar bueno pues vamos a ir de tres
hasta cero y después tendremos que bajar
una unidad más para así llegar al menos
uno por lo tanto tenemos que bajar
cuatro unidades ahora sí cuál va a ser
la magnitud de este vector bueno pues la
magnitud del vector doble y esto va a
ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de el
cambio en x lo cual ya sabemos que es 9
entonces lo voy a poner aquí 9 elevado
al cuadrado más el cambio en lo cual ya
sabemos que es menos 4 esto elevado al
cuadrado esto elevado al cuadrado y esto
aunque va a ser igual bueno pues
entonces puedo decir que la magnitud de
este vector w va a ser igual
a la raíz cuadrada de 9 al cuadrado lo
cual nos va a dar
81 81 más menos 4 al cuadrado lo cual es
16 16 positivo y bueno esto va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 81 16 lo
cual es 97 la raíz cuadrada del 97 y
ahora quiero que te des cuenta de dos
cosas la primera es que llegamos al
resultado a la magnitud de w sin dibujar
al vector solamente utilizando la
información que nos daban y otra cosa
que quiero que observes es que ahora
podemos escribir a este vector w en sus
componentes este vector w
va a ser el vector que tendrá como
componentes primero nos vamos a fijar en
el cambio en x el cual ya sabemos que es
9 su componente en x va a ser 9 y
después nos vamos a fijar en su cambio
en lo cual ya sabemos que es menos 4 por
lo tanto su compone
va a ser menos 4 ahora podemos decir que
el vector w
es el vector nueve coma menos cuatro y
bueno con esto también podríamos obtener
la magnitud de w
que va a ser la raíz cuadrada de la
componente x elevada al cuadrado lo
cuales 9 elevado al cuadrado más la
componente m elevada al cuadrado que es
menos 4 esto elevado al cuadrado y así
llegaríamos también a la raíz cuadrada
del 97 y ahora si lo queremos graficar
vamos a hacer nuestros ejes por aquí por
aquí voy a tener a mi eje bien y por
aquí voy a tener a mi eje x déjame ver
algo por aquí porque mi punto final es
el 2 menos uno y este de aquí va a ser
mi eje x mientras que este equipo va a
ser mi eje y brasil si queremos ver
nuestro punto inicial va a quedar en
este cuadrante 10 el punto menos 73 así
que me voy a mover menos siete unidades
en x
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete y tres
unidades hacia arriba y una dos tres así
que mi punto inicial que voy a poner de
color rojo va a ser el punto menos 73 el
cual está aquí aquí voy a tener a mi
punto inicial que es el menos 7,3 y
ahora con color café voy a poner a mi
punto final el cual va a estar en el 2
menos 1 así que voy a caminar 2 en x 12
y voy a bajar 1 en tiempo aquí va a
estar en el punto final el cual es el
2,21 y ahora sí si queremos ver a
nuestro vector w
va a ser el vector que tenga como punto
inicial este y como punto final este y
si ahora dibujo una flecha voy a poder
decir que ya tengo aquí a mi vector
doble
y ahora puedes ver que la longitud de
este vector es la raíz cuadrada de 97 es
la raíz cuadrada de 97 y bueno esta raíz
cuadrada de 97 sale de la fórmula de la
distancia entre dos puntos que vienen
del teorema de pitágoras del teorema de
pitágoras que sale del triángulo
rectángulo que tiene como lados al
cambio en x al cambio en jeff ya esta
longitud es decir que si nos fijamos en
el cambio en x éste va a ir desde el
valor de menos 7 desde este punto hasta
el valor de 2 hasta justo por aquí hasta
el valor de 2 y de ahí es donde sale
este valor de 9 así que la longitud de
este lado es 9 y el cambio en yemen va
desde el valor de igual a 3 hasta el
valor de igual a menos 1 lo cual nos da
un cambio total de menos 4 de menos 4 y
bueno solamente quiero hacer una
observación cuando nos tomamos los lados
de este triángulo nos vamos a tomar el
valor absoluto de estas
ya que para el teorema de pitágoras este
lado vale 9 y este lado vale 4 así que
ya tenemos aquí a nuestro triángulo
rectángulo y entonces se cumple que
nueva al cuadrado más 4 al cuadrado es
igual a la hipotenusa al cuadrado
así que h cuadrada es igual a 97 o dicho
otra manera la magnitud de este vector
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 97